ich will folgendes sagen ich
bin der Auffassung dass ins Grundgesetz
ein weiterer Artikel gehört und zwar
gleich nach Artikel 1 dass die Menschen
das Recht auf gute Laune haben denn ich
habe hier in Deutschland das Gefühl
langsam das Lachen verdächtig ist denn
ich habe viele Jahre im Ausland gelebt
in dem Vereinigten Staaten in Südamerika
ein Osteuropa kann wirklich sagen ich
habe viele Menschen unterschiedlichste
Art kennengelernt wenn man durch
Deutschland durch Berlin geht am Morgen
beispielsweise die Menschen haben alle
verkniffene Gesichtern hat den Eindruck
es ist ein Volkstrauertag das ganze Jahr
und das in einem der wirklich
wohlstandsländer dieser Erde es
beherrscht auch überhaupt kein offenes
kommunikationsklima es gibt so etwas wie
nicht wie ich es in Frankreich erlebt
habe im Sommer oder Italien so eine
kommunikative Leichtigkeit im Umgang
miteinander in Österreich ist es
übrigens auch der Fall das wundert mich
mögen diesen den deutschen ja ansonsten
nicht so fern auch wenn sie es nicht
wahrhaben wollen aber insofern bin ich
also über diese komische depressive ich
habe den Eindruck ich kam nun aus
Thailand das Land des Lächelns zuletzt
war ich in Thailand war vorher in vielen
anderen Ländern als Unternehmer mit
einer Firma ich habe also keine Zeit zum
Jammern gehabt so und ich musste
anpacken jeden Tag um Kohle zu machen
uns ganz klar zu sagen und auch meinen
Job zu machen ich finde hier in
Deutschland haben wir eine Missstimmung
und Unfreundlichkeit und das dazu kommt
etwas anderes ich habe nachgedacht
vorher liegt das kann ja nicht am alten
Germanen tun mit der Mann ich habe eine
Unfall an allensbach-analyse gelesen
nach der zwei Drittel der Deutschen das
ist viel sich nicht mehr trauen ihre
Meinung offen zu sagen und zwar zu
Genderfragen zu Fragen der Nation und
andere Fragen irgendwo muss es hier so
etwas wie ein stilles Schweigegebot im
Land geben das irgendwelche Leute zu
über die Lorenzo der bekannte Mann von
der Zeit hat gesagt das öffentliche
rechtliche Fernsehen verbreitet
Positionen und Meinung die von der
überwiegenden Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
gedeckt und das macht schlechte Laune
nein das macht den Menschen schlechte
Laune wir haben nein sie kriegen einen
Konflikt und ihre eigene Persönlichkeit
wenn ich einer Frau einen Kompliment
mache bin ich schon ein toxischer Mann
ist das so
zusammen man könnte ja dann trotz Krisen
Menschen in der Regel selbstständige
Unternehmer die haben gar nicht die Zeit
sich mit euch also wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe heißt das ja dann auch in
Zeiten wie diesen auch wenn wir
eigentlich nicht so viel zu lachen haben
könnte man die Krise ja auch ein
bisschen weglachen
Frau Neigel und dann läuft das schon ja
das mit dem positiven Denken läuft schon
da kann man sich schon viel hocharbeiten
sie haben gesagt jeder Mensch hat eine
Recht auf Glück das ist glaube ich eine
Verfassung in den USA finde ich auch
hier ganz ganz berechtigt weil dann
würde sich tatsächlich auch jeder dann
wird sich die die Politik auch um das
Glück der Bevölkerung kümmern und ich
persönlich kann ihn nur Recht geben in
ganz wichtiger Faktor
ich kann nicht ich behaupte das nicht
ich bin nur beobachtet
ganz kurz ich möchte einmal den Arzt
fragen wie wichtig ist gute Laune für
eine gesunde Seele ja natürlich extrem
wichtig wobei sie muss darf natürlich
nicht aufgesetzt sein ich muss ein Grund
haben und viele das wissen wir ja viele
Beschwerden in einer stadtpraxis ja sind
psychosomatisch vielleicht sogar 70 80
Prozent und das Spiel das ist der große
Rolle aber es tut mir leid ich muss da
noch mal auf das panikpapier das
Bundesinnenministeriums verweisen
anfangs der März Anfang 20 ja 2020 wo
explizit panikgeschwürde wurde wurden
Medien vorgemacht vorgeschrieben worden
quasi sollen den Erstickungstod der
Großeltern darstellen dass die Kinder
sich verantwortlich richtig übel und
wenn wir heute die Leute so griesgrämig
wenn wenn heute heute
schwer krank dass die Gegend Panik jetzt
sagen Sie was richtiges da muss man
wissen aufpassen dass wir da das nicht
in die andere verzwei als die Leute das
Gefühl geben Sie am Zeitpunkt das ist
auch übertrieben
haben
[Gelächter]
ich glaube dass die Leute schon
besonders gerade besorgt sind über die
Situation das mag ja ich mag übertrieben
sein oder auch nicht aber ich glaube es
gibt Anlass und ich sage dazu immer also
willst du auch darum geht weil sie
gesagt haben man kann niemand jetzt
überzeugen der in so verhärtet ist in
seiner Position ist aber man kann wenn
man andere überzeugen will zumindest
zeigen dass das ist bei sich schöner
zugeht das ist besser zugeht dass man
mehr Freude miteinander hat und hat ein
Kollege einen schönen Vergleich gebracht
er sprach vom Harry und sallyeffekt aha
was ist denn der Harry und Sally wenn
sie den Film gesehen haben aus den 80er
Jahren so die Jungs Komödie und sitzen
beide das Paar eben im Diner und sie
sagt viele Frauen
Spielende Orgasmus vor und und Harry
sagt nein das würde ich erkennen und
dann fängt sie an war richtig
ein Salat und die Dame am Nebentisch
sagt zum ober ich hätte gern genau gern
das auch und das zeigt einfach wenn ich
jetzt jemand nicht überzeugen kann ich
kann ihm mal zeigen bei uns geht's
lustiger zu freundlicher zu und kommt
und irgendwann wenn die wenn die anderen
die Wirklichkeit immer noch ablocken und
immer noch glauben wir haben die
Wahnsinns Pandemie ist alles so
gefährlich
dann sagen sie irgendwann mal das will
ich auch haben ich will mal raus aus
meinem aus meiner übertriebenen Angst
und vielleicht hat er da vielleicht in
diesem einen Punkt also ich
neige nicht zu Verallgemeinerungen aber
ein bisschen ist es schon ein deutsches
Problem
die Freiheit in Österreich ist genauso
eingeschränkt und nicht eingeschränkt
wie hier ja die Freiheit in Amerika ist
alle für größer ja und in Italien wo die
Leute mehr besser aufgelegt sind
positive schlecht gelauntes Volk ja aber
warum würde ich so nicht sagen ist es
historisch historisch begründen ich
glaube nicht ich glaube das einfach
durch diese ganze Krisen Geräte des
permanente ja alles ist eine Krise alles
ist furchtbar Leverkusen geht zugrunde
die Leute sterben aneinander
alles ist furchtbar ja wie soll sich
denn der einfache Mensch dagegen wehren
außer dass er Angst hat und schlecht
Gela lassen wir die Leute doch ein
bisschen Leben da geben Ihnen
für mehr Freude für und dafür brauchen
die Menschen Hoffnung sie brauchen
Hoffnung dass es gut wird und diese
Hoffnung wird Ihnen leider glaube ich im
Moment sehr sehr stark genommen
wir haben in Deutschland so tolle Leute
und wenn man die mal wieder mal mehr ran
lassen würde dann würde glaube ich ganz
schnell der vielleicht sogar einen Ruck
hier Herzog meinte durchs Land gehen und
die Leute würden Hoffnung führen die
Probleme als helfen Sie uns das ist die
Realität Freude am Schmerz aber sie
brauchen nein aber sie brauchen
Ohrenschmerzen
sondern ich möchte das Schlusswort
Hoffnung nehmen wir brauchen mehr
Hoffnung damit kann ich eigentlich diese
Runde wunderbar abschließen können wir
dann auch noch mal an die Regierung
weitergeben also hier wird sich
gewünscht von unserer Bundesregierung
geben Sie uns ein bisschen mehr Hoffnung
bisschen mehr Optimismus dann läuft das
vielleicht auch vielen Dank dass Sie bei
uns waren dankeschön fürs zuschauen bis
zum nächsten Mal bei 8:15